now as we know thousands of people are
coming here as we've stated
and they're running into a bit of an
obstacle many locals are getting too
familiar
familiar with there we go a ride share
shortage and it is creating some long
waits at mccarran
joe moeller spoke to travelers about it
he's live with what people are running
into
joe yeah well it's something that
travelers did not think
would be a problem but getting an uber
or lyft is proving to not be an easy
thing take a live look here at mccarran
these are all
folks waiting for their ride some
waiting more than 30 minutes
this was not what they expected
[Music]
it's crazy i wasn't expecting this but i
guess you know everybody needs to get
away right after
everything that's going on travelers
coming to las vegas are taking on the
crowds
and dealing with a shortage of rideshare
drivers my phone has been spinning and
spinning and spitting
can't find a ride i actually tried three
times three four times and
we couldn't get any driver getting a
ride was proving to not be an easy task
on uber
many switched to lyft and we were able
to get one but we had to spend a little
bit more money
lyft is actually faster than uber they
might not know that but i do
since restrictions started rolling back
the rideshare shortage has been an
ongoing problem
more people at the airport more people
coming in
i mean so business is picking up
rideshare driver william ireland says
there is no shortage of customers now
he says the governor's emergency order
to stop surge pricing
is one of the contributing reasons why
drivers are not returning to the road
from gas prices going up you know
locals don't tip you know what don't
expect a tip
ireland thinks bringing back surge
pricing would help but so would a pay
increase from uber and lyft yeah surge
pricing would be great but
you know they can always increase you
know the rate that they pay their driver
despite the weights people say they are
still happy to be here might as well
turn up in vegas can't turn up nowhere
else
now back out here live i did reach out
to uber and lyft today both
say they are offering incentives to get
drivers out there and they are working
with the governor on the surge
pricing concern and get this uber also
says that mccarran airport is actually
the most
in demand place when it comes to ubers
in the entire world
reporting live at mccarran joe mohler 8
news now